he was the Defensive Player of the Month
for September and that was a win
challenged month for this organization
which is now after starting on four
three and four and flat out back in the
mix and the Chargers are getting set to
go across the country and try and get
back to 500 at the expense of Tom Brady
in New England and a man who would love
to meet right at T be 12 alongside with
Joey Bosa joining us here on the Rich
Eisen show is one of the top pass
rushers in the league melvin ingram how
are you Melvin are you doing I'm doing
fine you are seemingly on a roll with
Joey Bosa right now off of that
defensive line what clicks for you to
god oh just everything man we we just
try to get to every plate and then we
got we got great cover glass now we got
a great cover guys we got great interior
lineman so when you put all their
together man we just try to get there
every play yeah you sound like my buddy
Warren Sapp that the back end in the
front and need to play together in order
have a defense definitely right and so
all right let's let's hit the Wayback
Machine what was not working early on in
this season for you guys melvin i
wouldn't say no ah there there wasn't
something that wasn't working it was
just we wasn't making them some critical
plays in the critical moments in the
game and i feel like i feel like we turn
over a new page in his second quarter of
the season we start making those
critical plays so what was that flight
like to new jersey to take on a Giants
team that was equally as winless and
essentially your season being on the
line it was a must-win flight man we all
knew that we knew we had to go get us
one get one out there and get it rolling
so that's what we did and the discussion
amongst yourselves as the losing kept
mounting was what we always gonna stay
together no matter what no weather times
all good no matter if it's called bad
we're gonna stick together and we just
stayed in the lab and we block me
outside world out and just kept it in
the building and we stayed in laughs and
how does Anthony Lin help with that
process
you knew heating up a lot with him he
stay on us day in and day out about
about being together holding each other
accountable and keep doing what we
supposed to do we know we trying to
follow 16 so no matter what we gotta
keep we gotta keep going
Melvin Ingram Chargers defensive end
currently fourth in the NFL will they
tan half sacks this season right here on
the Rich Eisen show how
much did the move affect you guys I
didn't say this at all as long as we got
a whistle football zip line breath we're
good
that's a great answer but I mean it
wasn't just a little bit out-of-body for
you too did you move for instance do you
still live I definitely moved around but
it won't out about it and it's a part of
the league really it's a part of your
job you know it's a possibility that can
happen so today it was difficult okay do
you have wife kids or you just a singing
yeah I got ya I got a grill in uh okay
so did you have to change schools former
and stuff like that
Melvin I mean yeah yeah definitely
definitely process okay so you're just
like locked in you go to the building
and you do your job and you try and ball
out you try and get the quarterback down
and you got Tom Brady this week what
challenge does that present to you
Melvin alright big guys uh he's one of
the best ever do it to be honest and and
we got a we we had to tip I head out to
him you gotta give respect straight dude
we got to come out of play for them
fundamentally sound football and get it
done okay
now you do realize that there is a bar
set by somebody from South Carolina
hitting somebody from Michigan on a
football field right now okay now do you
think you can do a little bit better
than Jadeveon Clowney in that bowl game
with Tom Brady standing back there no
way to see on Sunday you know this is a
quarterback friendly league so it is
kind of hard to put those types on
quarter okay
and now do you think that you should
have been flagged for that hit against
our definition uh what you say to the
rest at that time
Melvin's man I just told my that's a
good call real cool did you may argue
with him come on now you can there's no
way you can make up so you just got to
go with you got to turn the page to go
to the next player dude where'd you hit
him where'd you hit Semyon what's his
left shoulder that's where his right
shoulder okay are you gonna are you
gonna get a FedEx letter you this week
you think I shouldn't I shouldn't I
shouldn't but if I do I'll definitely
appeal it okay all right have you ever
seen a FedEx letter I'm not sure yeah
okay your FedEx letter means Chris
Brockman right fine I'll be fine I'll be
correct
the Los Angeles chargers joining me here
on the Rich Eisen show and his boat so
gonna be fired up to hit a Michigan man
I'm not sure we're gonna be ready to
play hmm what are you seeing on film
from Brady compared to other
quarterbacks that you've you've you've
looked at oh you just see what he wanted
a best to do it man he construct
everything out there and he he's very
accurate and throwing he's very good in
the pocket is everything made a great
Corvette okay now you're a prideful guy
Melvin most football players are but
certainly pass rushers in particular how
was it in September do you step out your
home sight field and then hear boos for
your team because there's peers to be
more fans of the opponent's in the
stands Melvin to be honest and I just
hear people in stands I don't hear
whether they pull in a chair know who
they chairing a boring [ __ ] I just I
just play football I don't hear none of
that outside stuff okay
Danni any of your teammates because I
know I know another guy named Melvin did
talk about it you know I know Gordon
talked about it a little bit and after
that oh no we don't talk about in the
locker room that's on we definitely
don't talk about it here okay so what do
you talk about in the locker room man we
do talk about everything outside outside
life now we get to know each other
outside like we talk about football of
course we got your wins well but we we
here doing football all day so we just
chillin and we just talking about what's
going on with people personalized okay
so Phillip Rivers is it does that
include his personal life as well he
wanna okay has anybody asked is he asked
anybody on the team to babysit for him
ever
no never once never it would be the best
babysitter for Phillip Rivers on I have
no clue and to be honest I how about you
what about you know I ain't into
babysitting kids well you have your own
yeah yeah so you wouldn't know how old
are your kids my son too
okay Simon you know you know Disney
Junior and you know all that stuff yeah
yeah I don't call that babysitting
wouldn't y'all here dog okay all right
so you have your own kids you're not
gonna what what a Philip offers you like
something like 20 bucks an hour or
something like that no I'm cool I'm cool
how about an Ingram Rivers playdate how
about that no I'm cool cool you
locked in man do you watch TV do you
watch TV shows yeah what do you have
what you want what do you want a little
Martin little more than SportsCenter I
want football and Mark Martin like
Martin Lawrence from back in the day
mark Melvin that's old-school I mean
that's it I'm old school man
anything else anything else do you go so
old-school on SportsCenter from back
when I was on it or no I'll go to that
Bible turn I'm carrying on now all right
Melvin go hunt that Tom Brady and we'll
see if you go four and four let's see
what and then let's do this because I've
enjoyed our conversation you have a bye
week after that you want to come here
and hang them in the studio with me here
in Los Angeles they'll be great yeah I
might come by I might come on Holly come
on up okay let's do that
I'll bring my three kids and you bring
your kids will have a playdate here okay
hang out okay Melvin all right have a
safe flight to New England that's Ingram
on Twitter here on the Rich Eisen show
for more Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app